hey all it's energy couch here in this
tuesday video we're not going to be
looking at this week's data set
instead we're going to focus more on the
tidy models package
and extend it towards the post modeling
process
specifically in determining the correct
model um and i got this inspiration from
a week ago because just to give a live
update
uh i recently accepted a data scientist
position
for a logistics company and um during
the interview process they actually gave
me
a assessment where i had to create a
model for them
and one of the problems um well that i
faced
while creating the models was i had two
models
at very similar uh performance metrics
specifically in the auc scores
so i was trying to decide you know which
model should i be choosing for the final
submission
so i figured um i could kind of go over
my workflow and
thought process when determining the
optimal optiple model
when these models are essentially tied
so for our data set we're actually going
to use the telco customer churn
data set where churn means
um basically uh customers who left
within the last month
so we're basically trying to predict
whether a customer will leave our
company
so we're going to load up a tidy uh
nr markdown file i'll call this tidy
tuesday
model eval
uh erase all this stuff load in the
aniverse uh type new models
and then i'll just read in our csv which
is called customer
turn.csv okay
just let's look at the summary so just
look at all the features
right so we have a customer id uh
gender senior citizen so these things
we look at senior citizen it's just
zeros and ones i'm assuming
um partner and then we have our turn
right there
so when i'm looking at this one thing
we're gonna have to remove is customer
id
our customer id could be useful if we
wanted to do say a bunch of like feature
engineering
with that customer we had other data
um but we're probably gonna we're gonna
remove customer id
we're gonna have to do some data
cleaning because i think some of them
are characters
some of those are ones and zeroes um etc
so there's gonna be some uh data
cleaning that'll be pretty simple
uh let's see what else addition we have
some nas
and total charges so i just want to look
at
um the amount of row so we have about
7000 rows
so what i'm going to do is actually drop
the missing values so
drop n a it so i would say
um look at
summary of the data set
and then remove the
nine missing values cool
so since we have all this stuff we
should probably start cleaning it
so what i'm gonna do is i'm just gonna
uh i'm gonna say mutate all
and i'm to say all these uh values
should be as that factor
okay however what we do know is that
tenure
should not be a factor what else should
and monthly charges shouldn't be a
factor in total charges
so we can just convert those so mutate
tenure equals as numeric tenure
uh was it monthly
charges equals as dot numeric
monthly charges and then total
charges is equal as dot numeric total
charges great
just going to look at the summary just
to make sure we're not doing anything
wrong
so gender these are factors
tenure is numeric
let the charger total charges okay sweet
so
i think that's all the data cleaning uh
yeah so i'm gonna just assign that to
our original data frame
say uh convert
uh features to relevant
data types okay
now we have that we can actually start
creating our
uh training test set uh training test
splits i just wanted to say that
um we're going to focus more on the post
modeling process over the actual like
uh feature engineering data cleaning uh
stuff like that i think i've made a
decent amount of videos on
that stuff beforehand so we're gonna
focus on one specific thing
so i'm gonna go a little bit faster uh
on this bottling
so i'm gonna create a recipe called tidy
recipe or tidy rack
i'm going to use all the features
first i'm going to do step remove and
that's going to be
what's it called again
so customer id so we'll say customer
id step normalize
all numeric
and then i'll just do step dummy
all nominal minus
all outcomes
uh oops oh oops
wow actually uh let me create the
training test sets first
training test set i train test sets
so create training test sets and then
i'll do what is it set dot
seed equals 42 i tidy
split initial split
um data frame we're going to want to do
a 80 20 split so proportionate goal is
80. i'm also going to strap do stratify
based off of
uh churn so that way um
each trained test set will have the same
proportion of um
positive and negative churns so we'll
create our train data
data uh training try to
win
and i'll do what was it v-fold maybe
got that so we create our training test
sets i created also a 10-fold
cross-validation
um i'm going to look at i'm going to
prep my recipe just to see what it's
doing
so let's see here variables remove
customer id
center and scaling for 10-year monthly
charges total charge great dummy
variables etc
cool so now let's actually just create
our models
um what i'm going to do is i'm going to
create three models which i think
are probably the most common models
you'll see um
one of the first ways to actually create
and determine
um whether a model is performing well is
create a baseline model
and with the baseline model i think the
best baselines are usually
like linear models so if you're doing a
classification model use a logistic
regression if you're doing a
regression problem use linear regression
so i'm going to do logistic reg set mode
location set engine
vlm may also notice that in my past
videos i usually put the parameters that
i want to tune
in this case for this video i'm not
going to tune any of the parameters
um but we you can definitely um i think
generally you'll be tuning parameters so
uh just for you know
just just make this video a little bit
faster and we don't have to kind of
worry about the tuning
uh we'll just kind of leave them as
their default um primers which tiny
models does a pretty good job on
all right so once we have our baseline
which is expression i'm going to make
two models a random forest and an xg
boost model
i think those are kind of like the
default predictive modeling
models that people use and it's a pretty
common model
so we're gonna do that
okay so now we have our three models
what i'm actually going to do is i'm
just going to use
our 10 fold cross validation
using our default parameters and just
fit them to those um
10 folds what this will do is kind of
give us some
um give us some of the metrics that we
want to look at
um over 10 uh 10 folds or 10
train and test sets so it kind of gives
us a reasonable um
look at how well our models are doing
and our model stability
so i'm going to say fit free samples
logistic res fit free samples
logistic oops it's called baseline
model we're going to give it our recipe
and we're going to also give it our tiny
k
folds okay and then we'll say
random forest press
oops random forest model
tidy wreck tidy k folds
and then we'll do our finally our hd
boost
model i will say fit free samples
actually boost model teddy wreck
teddy k bolts okay so i'm gonna
fit these three models
okay and this will probably take a few
minutes so i'm going to kind of go over
what why we're doing um this first
so my number one thing that we should
probably do for determining the optimal
model
is to evaluate it based off their
baseline model
so that's why we created the logistic
regression model and basically if our
random forest
or actually boost model does not perform
the same
perform with the same particular power
as our baseline model
we can pretty much choose the simpler
model or our baseline model
so if we're using say compared
uh an xg boost model compared to
a say a a mars model
versus a baseline model um we would
definitely look at the baseline model
first
however we would also want to kind of
evaluate how complicated a model is
so generally actually boosts and random
forest models
are more complicated than say a mars
model
or a general glm model
so if all else is equal you should
choose this simpler model
oops what it was what did i do tidy
um so we're gonna
we're almost done with our fit i'm just
gonna do that
and if we just kind of look at our
logistic oh what is it res
we can see our results what i'm actually
gonna do
is create a list uh put these
um fit free sample results
into a table so what i'll do is tibble
model equals list logistic res
uh random forest res actually
boost res
so we have a list of the resample
results
um i'm also going to create a model name
just for clarity
so logistic random forest
uh actually boost and you might be
wondering why didn't i just
put uh these models into a table and
then
map this function if it resamples
because i'm essentially just copy and
pasting this
um three times um i actually tried it a
few days ago and i kept on running into
errors
i'm not sure if it's just because what
fit resamples it's doing something in
the back end that
confuses the mapping function but i it
just wouldn't work for
what i was doing maybe i was just typing
in the code wrong but
it's definitely an option i just
couldn't get it to work when i was
working through it
so we're just going to do this model res
um and what we really want to do with
our model res
is i'm just going to use the baseline
model as a
oral uh logistic res as an example
so what we want to do is basically oops
is select the fold and then the
the metrics and when we we want to
unness the metrics
so that way we can figure out all of our
metrics for each fold
and we want to do that to all the models
so we can do is basically
a mapping function so we can say um
map collect metrics
give it a function i always like to give
it the
what i'm actually going to put an input
into so like the input
um right i like to name the input what i
have
as my um column name so i'm just going
to say model
and the model i'm going to say select id
dot
metrics and then unnested so not a
complicated function
you could definitely put it into the map
um as is but it looks a little bit
cleaner
okay so we have our model res what i'm
going to do is
mutate res is equal to map
model map clock metrics
and now we have our metrics i'm also
going to select the model
name and the res and then i'm going to
uns res
so now we have all of our models
um key metrics so accuracy and roc and
a roc aoc for every fold
which means we have about 60 um
different uh rows or 30
um you know model models that we can
evaluate from each fold
okay so i'm actually going to put this
into that
okay so i'm going to say uh create
a table model
results create a
helper function for collecting the
metrics and apply
a helper function and extract
the metrics
so then what we're going to do is go to
model res and we do a simple gg plot
so we'll just oops what we're going to
do is just
ggpot aes x equals model
name y goes dot estimate
i just want to see a box plot i'll fasta
wrap it by the dot
metric scales is equal to free
y uh dot s
[Music]
dot estimate okay so what we can see
here
is that basically our logistic
regression model
is beating most the random force and xg
boost model
um from like the median so
50 of the logistic regressions
models we're beating the random forces
50
or whatever okay um so this is something
where
i would definitely um lean towards the
logistic regression model
however we can see there's there is some
overlap so
although the logistic regression has
definitely a tighter quartile
range um that's higher up there are
times
when you know random force and extra
boost
uh are above um the logistic regression
model so there's some overlap between
these two
between the three models additionally
with the roc aoc
we can see that um yes the ultra
regression model still has a higher rsc
slash aoc score
however xg boost has more variability
and this kind of a great example where
if you use my
the first rule that i was talking about
i was just just selecting the simpler
model
then we could just do logistic
regression and call it a day right there
but um we're not sure yet because
on one hand which is regression uh the
final logistic regression model could
just
underperform these two models and also
intuitively um
since we didn't really tune the random
force and actually boost models
they're not going to perform as well as
a logistic regression model which
basically has no tuning parameters
so i wouldn't be i wouldn't say this
should always happen where
logistic regression will always be right
in the force actually boost
just because we probably didn't tune it
and it seems that these random forces
actually be smallest needed to be tuned
to the data set so
since we have just this baseline kind of
summary statistics
of our our model metrics let's look at
um the model metrics through each fold
so we have our model res what we can do
is create a g ggplot
uh model name y equals dot
estimate in this case we're going to say
the colors is equal to the id
or the actual fold then we'll do a gm
line plus asset wrap
scales is equal to
three y oops and then i need to
add i think a group aesthetic which is
the id
okay so what what can what we can see
here is that
there is some variability in the
um and the folds
right so for logistic regression we can
see that
was it full volt 10 has a very high
accuracy
compared to fold 9. 5.78 to 0.83
probably which is a decent amount of
variability
we can also see that um let's see
that there are some times when like for
the folds
um like random forest will have a bet
higher accuracy
than which is regression but then on a
different fold say for example
fold 10 logistic regression has a higher
higher accuracy than random force
so you can see how they they're
basically changing right they're
changing in what's the better score
which means that i would definitely
be a little bit more critical or a
little bit more skeptical about
whether i believe logistic regression is
better than random forest etc
with roc aoc it seems pretty it seems a
little bit more consistent
where um in general like
logistic regression will be beating uh
the random forest
model however random for however the
logistic regression actually boosts
seemed to be a little bit more similar
and
uh they might be varying a little bit
uh let's finally finally kind of look at
a little bit more
um let's look at uh this metric
in a more uh refined area so let's look
at the density of it
um we'll do a ggpot
estimate why oh uh was it color equals
model
name fill equals model name
okay so what we can see here is that
basically um the logistic regression
model definitely seems to be
um outperforming these um the other
models
but we can still see that we can't be
sure that the logistic regression model
is the superior model um
one thing that i would say is when
you're trying to evaluate models
it's nice to have a secondary metric
so um on one hand since our
our uh our data set i think is
relatively even so if we look at our df
and say
count turn
oh so it isn't it isn't very so
this is this is something where we can
see that okay since our
um data set isn't as even as we thought
i'm because i didn't really look at it
we can see that accuracy is not our best
metric that we should be looking at
in fact what we should really be looking
at is roc aoc
which is kind of nice because if if we
see there are our
are our was our classes are
um a little bit imbalanced we should be
using roc
aoc scores as it's as it's more um
it's more suited for an imbalanced data
set however we always still have
accuracy and we can kind of use that as
our secondary metric
so if we look at our model results
um oops and we just do like a group by
model name and then dot metric
summarize oh like mean equals
mean dot estimate so
if we look at this we can see that okay
our logistic regression
definitely has a higher roc aoc score
and it's essentially tied with our xg
boost model who has a similar roc
c score we can kind of use our secondary
metric
which is accuracy as a tie breaking
score so
in general our logistic regression
outperforms actually uh both random
force and xg boost
in the roc aoc score however which is a
regression also beats
um uh the all the other models in
accuracy
so that could also be another um reason
why we would choose the logistic
regression model
because um it beats all the other models
with our primary
metric which is roc and it and it also
beats our other models with our
secondary metric
but we can also do one more step which
is to use um tidy posterior
uh which is which uses the resampled or
the 10 folds
to basically analyze the distributions
of our metrics
and to estimate um how how certain we
can be
that our model is better than the other
models
which seems pretty useful in this case
so what we're going to do
is we're going to have to convert it to
a kind of like a traditional format so
what i'm going to do is i'm going to
select the
model name id
oops actually i'm what i'll do is first
is all filter.metric
is equal to rlc aoc because
since our our data set is in balance i'm
going to just
switch over to our primary metric which
is roc aoc
we're going to filter that we're going
to select the model
name id and dot estimate oop
well that's meant wrong dot estimate
and then what we're going to do is we're
going to do a pivot wider
names from is equal to model name
values for oops that was from equals
dot dot oops dot
estimate okay so now we basically have
10 rows
where each row represents a fold from
our cross val
k full cross validation and our roc
score
for all all the models it's pretty
useful
what i'll call this is we'll say model
uh
pos
um and now what we're gonna do is load
in
the tidy posterior package
so tidy posterior
and what i'm going to create is a
i'll say roc aoc model and what i'm
going to run is the perf
mod which basically does it says it
basically analyzes the differences
between our roc auc scores between the
models
with the uh the folds
i'll give it a model on our server pause
i'll set the seed to 42.
and now you can see it using um stan
to basically randomly sample and uh
sample the
data data set and evaluate um
how certain we can be that our logistic
regression model is
superior to the other models
oops so we can kind of look at our was
it roc
it's oops here you see model
luckily since it's part of the tiny
models we can just do tidy
and then we can have our posterior
distributions
um which could which is pretty useful we
can also do
our roc ac model uh tidy it
and give it a gg pot
and it'll give us the actual like violin
plots of the distribution
so we can see we can see how um the
variance between
um the the fold is uh pretty even
between the models
um we can also do the a s x equals model
y equals the t stick
plus g gm point
that we have points on there just to see
um and lastly what we really want to
look at
is the contrast models function if we do
contrast
models and give it our roc aoc
model we can see how
uh we can look at this and say okay but
comparing logistic to random forest
which is the first random force the
difference is point zero zero five
okay um so this can give us kind of
the idea of what we want to look at
um luckily we also have uh since it's
we have a gt plot functions for it so if
we do contrast
models rlc aoc model
and just do a gdpot it'll give us
essentially like a a comparison or a
pairwise comparison between the models
so what we can look at is how how much
better is our logistic regressions aoc
score
what's the posterior probability of it
we see it's above
zero so we have some type of certainty
that our logistic regression is better
than random
the random force model as opposed to our
logistic regression and our xg
boost model we can see there's some
overlap between point zero
which means that um i wouldn't be a
certain thyroid which
expression is better than our sg boost
model however
since our logistic regression model is
the simpler model
i would definitely um say that we should
go with this logistic regression model
given our set of tuning parameters and
our data set
so essentially um if our random forests
are actually boost model
um if we want to compare these two um we
can see that okay our random forest
model
is definitely has you know a slight
decrease input and the difference
between the roc
aoc scores which basically means that um
we can we can be uh we can be a little
certain that our actually beast model
is a little bit better than random fours
however there is a little bit of overlap
between the zero
which means that um it may just be a
fluke on the differences
so the tight posterior package sounds
pretty complicated especially when you
see that it uses
it uses like stan i think he uses like
our stand arm
but in reality it really it doesn't
really come with a lot of functions
so if we look up the tidy posterior it
only comes with
basically perf mod tidy um
and some random helper things so and so
it basically comes with the contrast
models
perf mod and tidy so the perf mod is the
main thing which creates the
bayesian model to analyze it there's a
lot of different things you can do with
it
for example if you look at um
if we look at our profile you can see
okay first of all just to go back on
this
is we can see that there's not a lot of
functions it's basically perf mod and
contrast models
but with a perf mod there are things
that we can add into it
so we can add some transformations um
which is definitely useful um if we have
a certain metric that might be
uh needing some type of transformation
we can also see like hetero variants
so um by default it says false which i
believe it means it doesn't use
a like random intercept let's see here
um so that might be useful so if you
want to turn it back
to true um
that might that might work too but in
general um just leaving it
as is with no set um
just like giving it with the data frame
and then setting the seed it'll just
assume
uh was it a random distribution
which would be useful for just analyzing
basically most of the models that
you'll be looking at the by default a
generalized linear model
with gaussian gaussian error
so i know this is a pretty um simple
video um we only
we basically went over one function but
this is actually a pretty useful thing
and hopefully you might um have an
interview where you
need to do this and it'll be pretty
useful
so i'll see you guys next week and tidy
on